rain showers and as we're here now
officially in Spring looks like we might
be getting some more in eight Tannenbaum
joining me across the studio for a look
at our first forecast no question about
that Heather we did have a couple of
waves of rain during the morning commute
we caught a little bit of a break right
now and we're still waiting for the wind
to kick in but let's see what's going on
out at Reid International Airport as we
continue to keep an eye on the
possibility of more rain we're at 53
degrees right now and there the wind is
steadily out of the southeast at 11 but
gusting only close to 20 miles an hour
that could double or even triple and
here are those waves of rain that rolled
on through this morning well we've got
that little break right now we are
anticipating more rain not only this
afternoon but through tonight as well
that's where the national weather
service has that wind advisory that the
areas of light blue here the areas of
white that's a winter storm warning
that's going to run until five tomorrow
evening where they could get upwards of
eight inches of additional snow so the
weather headlines the wind advisory for
Las Vegas till five tomorrow morning
maybe upwards of a quarter of an inch of
additional rain game and temperatures
are staying in the 50s for the next
couple of days stay tuned for the eight
day forecast in a few minutes we'll see
if we have any additional changes we'll
be telling you about in just a few
minutes Heather okay